[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ]
[Music]
row
throw a little republican jesus in there
we have a talk show today
holy moly did you
i've been trying to catch up on some
video here to see what we were gonna
show today did you guys re-watch
this uh this video of mark short
absolutely trashing
matt gatz oh my god
just wads that little punk up and tosses
him in the [ __ ] trash
whoosh mark short on cnn we're gonna
watch that clip that's crazy
um he is having no more [ __ ] to give
about matt gatz mark short has not
um
but
this morning one of the stories that are
coming out of course is the hulu and
we'll get to that i want to ask gabe
sanchez his opinion there but
we're go also going to have texas paul
join us at the bottom of the hour all
the texas paul fans out there today's
tuesday
and he's going to give us the texas
tuesday breakdown i don't know what
we're going to call yet i haven't i
haven't exactly figured this out yet
uh but paul's joining us at the bottom
of the hour there is a story from texas
that he is going to give us some a
little bit of reporting on
so we will go through that story at the
bottom of the hour with texas paul the
midas mighty favorite over on the midas
touch network
oh
where shall i start also there's
flooding in st louis in missouri in the
state i'm in um some crazy video coming
uh from i-70 and i-44 where a lot of
cars were stranded on the highway
a lot of those roadways could not the
drainage systems could not keep up with
the record rainfall
and so we have a lot of flooding looks
like there's going to be a lot of
property damage it's going to cost the
state and the government a [ __ ] ton of
money because they won't you know they
won't listen these republicans won't
listen when we say hey there's actual
cost when it comes to ignoring climate
change
and global warming you [ __ ] idiots
there's cost to it not just not just
cost in the environment but real cost to
our infrastructure
if you're not paying attention
stop
sticking your head in the sand or up
your ass pluck it out
and let's do some [ __ ] to try to move
this forward
so flooding in st louis this morning now
let's see what else what else is in the
news today
what else do we have going on
um we also have jd vance i don't know if
you saw that jd vance does not do he's
on the side of a wife beater
that that that white beater should
definitely definitely
be able to beat their wife and stay
married and there should be no cause for
anyone to leave a marriage even if it's
violent what a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
what is this nonsense about the sexual
revolution and all this garbage
what the [ __ ] are they talking about how
the sexual revolution tried to change
marriage no the sexual revolution they
just wanted to have sex the way they
want to leave them the [ __ ] alone
why why does everyone have to get
married why does everyone have to fit in
their [ __ ] box because they're
fascist that's why
everyone has to fit in their [ __ ] box
and if they don't well
get rid of them
make sure they can't do what they want
to do
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] whoopi
goldberg apparently is in the news as
well i haven't seen the clip
but i'm sure uh whoopi uh made a
statement
on the view and that's why she's
trending so i put her in the trend also
the international space
station is trending apparently russia is
butt hurt
that the entire world has turned against
them in their effort to invade and
murder and commit war crimes against a
sovereign nation of ukraine
the mega millions lottery is in the is
in the news too that son of a [ __ ] is
up to like 800 million dollars so if you
don't want to win the lottery go buy you
a ticket
oh [ __ ]
it would be kind of cool to win 810
million dollars you know what i would do
with 810 million dollars i would make
sure that the choco taco went nowhere
we did not discontinue the choco taco
810 million minus taxes
could probably afford you to stop i'm
just kidding i'm just kidding i wouldn't
do the whole elon musk thing where you
do something that isn't good for
humanity i don't know maybe the choco
taco puts enough smile on enough faces
that
it would be good for for humanity i'm
also alex jones is in the news that
trial starts
for for his uh
his slander against the sandy hook
parents and families where he lied and
lied and lied and turned his supporters
his trolls
in real life against those folks
so today
i guess today i think today it starts
the trial so he's trending
as well
so we got a lot of stuff to talk about
today but this first thing is the title
of the show roberts versus row
i don't know if i buy all of this story
yet
i need to really sniff out some more of
this story before
now i decide exactly if this story is
true
here's the thing
they're claiming in the story it's
claiming that
john roberts the chief justice since
december had pressured uh specifically
brett kavanaugh
because brett kavanaugh seemed to be
sympathetic
to not overturning roe v wade which with
roberts and kavanagh would have gained
the majority to not overturn roe v wade
you know that this this dobbs case in
mississippi
it really wasn't about overturning roe v
wade but the courts made it that he's
bought and paid for justices these
fascists
who want to strip away rights from women
that's nothing to do with abortion not a
god damn thing we need to stop talking
about it as if it does you [ __ ]
boneheads
that is not what it is about
and i think texas paul with this story
from texas this morning is going to tell
us at the bottom of the hour why this is
not about abortion
it's not about jesus christ or running
around the country going oh well if you
have this medical procedure that's
called an abortion it's not really an
abortion so it's not illegal but it is
it [ __ ] is you lying sacks of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
they really they really are not gonna
give up on this lying in this fascism
stuff folks they're not going to and and
the reason why is because it's not about
abortion it's not it never [ __ ] was
about children dying or saving the
children abortion or whatever the [ __ ]
whatever kind of words they want to slam
together
to make it seem like they're not against
women and against rights it's about
fascism it's about telling people they
don't want to have power you don't get
to have power you don't get to have
rights you don't get to have [ __ ]
liberty that's what it is about
it is about making sure that people they
don't want to have power and rights and
liberty in this country and they white
dudes who look like me
get to decide who the [ __ ] gets the
power and who doesn't and when they do
and when they don't
you have [ __ ] marjorie taylor green
running around talking about christian
nationalism she's a [ __ ]
nazi this is nazis they're [ __ ] nazis
and i know you're like well my my i have
a relative that supports this stuff and
they're not a nazi yes they are they may
not know it you may not know it but this
is the way it happened in germany
everyone didn't just wake up one day and
have the swastika on their sleeve
it was a slow burn to that type of
fascism just like we're seeing now just
like what ron desantis is trying to test
in florida
he's working on a an american fascist
motto in florida for the government
and he's trying to sell that path
forward so he has some sort of
opportunity in 2024
which donald trump is really [ __ ]
scared of that because he keeps putting
out poles where he beats desantis as if
anyone should give a rat's [ __ ] ass
about 2024 in the first place [ __ ] that
race that's the next big race the race
right now in front of us is 20 22.
that's the [ __ ] race we can win and
speaking of jd vance
and wanting and wanting women to get
beaten by their [ __ ] husbands there
you go more of the same
[ __ ] jd vance doesn't want a woman to be
able to get divorced even though her
husband is violently beating her
because of god christians
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you this is exactly this
is exactly why we're having big pushback
from these [ __ ] christian
nationalists in these countries these
nazis and the reason why is because they
want to ostracize anyone anyone even
actual christians the real ones marjorie
taylor green who actually believe in the
the new testament who actually practice
what jesus said you [ __ ] bonehead
i'm talking to marjorie taylor green
lauren bobert and the likes
there are people out there who consider
themselves christian who do not go to
church because of people like you
americans are [ __ ] sick of it to tell
you what you can what you can't believe
even inside your own goddamn church who
you're supposed to vote for and what
your your [ __ ] political views are
supposed to be
people don't want that [ __ ] and they
don't definitely they definitely do not
want to be told what the [ __ ] to do
inside a doctor's office which the
mothers against greg abbott have a great
new ad i want to play that ad today i'm
going to play that at four
texas paul because he's in texas that's
texas news that's greg abbott
but this christian nationalism is on the
march it's on the move now the good news
is that a lot of americans don't buy
into this nonsense they know buying this
[ __ ] but capitulation and silence
could advance it it did in germany they
stood back and watched the nazis take
power they stood back and watched them
take control of the social structure of
the country
to start taking rights and liberty away
from certain groups of people
and they said nothing they didn't do
anything
and that was the slow burn to the
fascist state that we know as nazi
germany
we cannot let that happen here
the good news is we have a strong
democracy that stands in the way of
these fascists
unlike nazi germany germany at the time
did not have a strong democracy
they did not have a strong electorate
it was much easier
but hitler tried a violent coup
with his brown shirts the essay
and they were unsuccessful he went to
prison jesus christ is the book we talk
about all the time mind conf that he
wrote in prison
when he left prison he decided that
taking the country by violence was not
the way to take power it was to take
power using the government that was
already in place and to install
themselves into the government
now
let's fast forward to now right [ __ ]
now right [ __ ] here and look what is
happening you have a united states
elected official a congresswoman from
georgia who has no committee meetings
she is basically worthless as far as
that district's congress person and she
is on the airwaves anytime she can any
microphone she can get in front of and
she's saying hey
i'm a nazi and i'm proud of it
she's saying that she's telling us who
the [ __ ] she is
and she's one of their biggest [ __ ]
fundraisers she's one of their biggest
[ __ ] stars jesus christ matt gatz her
[ __ ] america first nazi buddy was on
stage talking about women's bodies and
[ __ ] and how fat they are and how not
ugly they are and that's why they want
abortions
it really is [ __ ] dumb
she stole a [ __ ] joke from george
carlin that piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] and
we're gonna we're gonna we're we're
gonna watch a video about mac ads here
in just a bit
where mark short the former chief of
staff to mike pence who has apparently
now the news the real news the relevant
news there is that mark short
was deposed by a a criminal grand jury
that has to do with the january 6
insurrection in dc
that doesn't sound good
for donald trump
and his allies
especially since we
have the stories that john eastman and
jeffrey clark has had their electronic
devices taken
speaking of trump allies i also have
video of rudy giuliani i want to show
you it's really short i promise it's
really short you don't have to bear
through much of the
grandpa farty mcsharty rudy giuliani but
we'll get to
rudy kaluti today as well
but these fascists are not going to stop
and this roberts this roberts case where
we have the fascist court
a brett kavanaugh
gorsuch amy coney barrett that
handmaid's tale [ __ ] listen
they are trying to convince you that
they were trying not to overturn roe v
wade
i don't buy the story
i don't buy it
if that was true why the [ __ ] why the
[ __ ] was robert's vote
to overturn roe v wade if he was so
hell-bent on saving it if he was so
stuck to his [ __ ] principles since
december get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ]
in december what they're reporting this
is what they're reporting in december
roberts was campaigning
was lobbying
brett kavanaugh specifically because
brett kavanaugh showed that he had an
interest in hearing what the chief
justice was going to say about not
overturning roe v wade
and now what they're claiming is the
leak is the thing that was the straw
that broke the camel's back in brett
kavanaugh's case and robert's case well
why
why just because we saw the despicable
nature of these bought and paid for
fascists that are on our court that's
what made you go up well then i'm gonna
be with the fascist give me a [ __ ]
break i actually don't believe a goddamn
word of this story to be quite honest
with you
i believe that roberts probably saw that
there was
that there was weakness
in this country that it would show
weakness
that it would turn back time it would
turn back liberty for certain people in
this country that these [ __ ] fascists
that are out and about banging on our
front door trying to destroy our
democracy
would only embolden them this decision
and it has
this [ __ ] idea that
abortion was about states rights and all
that nonsense that they spewed on us and
puked on us for [ __ ] decades and
years it's all [ __ ] they're trying
to get a national ban now
and they don't just want to ban abortion
they want to ban contraception they want
to ban they want to ban same-sex
marriage they want to they want to ban
their racial marriage they want to turn
back time to win the white dude was in
charge of [ __ ] in everything and if
you had anything to say about it he
would smack you down and there ain't a
goddamn thing you can do about it
because they're [ __ ] little [ __ ]
and their butt hurt
in this country these [ __ ] white
fragile males
and their [ __ ] arm cairns like
marjorie taylor greene and lauren bobert
who are [ __ ] nazis in and of
themselves it's they're nazis they're
[ __ ] nazis god damn it call them out
if you got an uncle if you got an ant
they're like yeah well i really i really
like trump i really like marjorie taylor
green you say oh so you're a nazi
oh you're a nazi now that's what you
tell them [ __ ] em
[ __ ] em [ __ ] em [ __ ] em call em out
it's enough of this [ __ ] where we gotta
beat around the bush and make them feel
safe in this country that they don't get
called nazis [ __ ] that [ __ ]
if you identify as a christian
nationalist at this moment in time in
this moment in history you start going
out there and yapping america first and
all this [ __ ] kkk [ __ ] well guess
what you're a [ __ ] nazi
and if you're on their side you're a
[ __ ] nazi because if 10 people are
sitting at the table
having dinner with one just one nazi
there are 11 [ __ ] nazis at that
goddamn table
that's how it works
and that's the slow burn that they want
roberts knew it that's this cover of
this story to make it look like that
john roberts didn't want to overturn roe
v wade
so that he doesn't get yelled and
screamed at when he goes and has a steak
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you he's he's all he's all worked
up because brett kavanaugh can't go dunk
his steak and catch up at a restaurant
well eat at home you little punk [ __ ]
eat at home
and we'll yell and scream from the
sidewalk there
it's ridiculous
john roberts trying to save his hide
here with this story
acting like
acting like the leak is the thing that
changed their minds
that changed their minds you're telling
me you're telling me that these fascist
[ __ ] who wanted to take away liberty
and rights away from women all of them
anywhere they could anyhow any way that
they could with this decision to
overturn roe v wade to basically strike
down that women had the liberty to
bodily autonomy you're telling me that
it was the leak oh boy we got exposed so
it really it really made us go all in
what the [ __ ]
i don't think so i don't believe that
for one goddamn second and i i i the
journalist who is on this story she's a
credible journalist but i do not believe
this [ __ ]
i don't believe it not for a second
this is more bull sizing of the [ __ ]
john roberts voted to get rid of women's
[ __ ] bodily autonomy period you don't
need the [ __ ] history of it he voted
to take down women's liberty to take
away their [ __ ] rights
period
that's the story that's the headline you
don't need anything else what the [ __ ]
else do you need
so we'll get to the bottom of that
we're going to have texas paul on
because we're going to talk about a
story in texas uh where this road the
overturning of roe has affected
dozens and hundreds of women in texas
and to affect thousands
before the year is out maybe even tens
of thousands of women before the year is
out it just depends on how far these
fascists want to go inside the state
legislator and how far that fascist
greg abbott will go we also have a video
that i want to show um of greg our
mother's mom's against greg abbott
um so we want to show that video as well
it's uh it's it's it's actually funny
they use humor to show you what the [ __ ]
is gonna happen
yep
it's it's it's it's gonna get bad in
these red states and they want it to
happen in these blue states they're
hell-bent on it they can't stop talking
about it on the floor of the house of
representatives just go to c-span hell
you can probably go to c-span right now
and there's probably one of these
fascist mouthpiece mouthpieces on the
house floor talking about a national
abortion ban and how it's going to save
children and how they're trying to save
lives blah blah blah blah blah not
[ __ ]
and then they give you this nonsense
about how what is an abortion and what
isn't
[ __ ] boneheads
it really it really is infuriating
but you are the one who can save this
democracy because that's what they're
actually scared of
they're actually scared of democracy
because democracy delivers equality and
equity yes it's hard and no it's not as
fast as we'd like jesus christ
after several hundred years we're where
we're at today and we have just in the
last five turn back the clock 20.
so democracy is difficult it's hard and
when you make big mistakes
it costs a lot inside that democracy we
cannot make these mistakes again
we cannot keep putting these fascists in
charge of our government
they're not conservatives they're not
republicans
they're not supply ciders they're not
the ronald reaganites that you [ __ ]
remember they're not they're [ __ ]
nazis
jesus christ they're identifying
themselves as nazis
christian nationalists come on
christian nationalist
self-identifying as nazis it's [ __ ]
ridiculous so we're gonna go we're gonna
go here in just just under five minutes
we're gonna go to texas paul i believe
gabe sanchez my co-host is gonna join us
for that conversation with texas paul
about texas on tuesdays tuesday morning
in texas i don't know what do you guys
think we should call this thing
tuesday mornings in texas with texas
paul
i know because
every tuesday paul's gonna join us
the minus mighty favorite texas paul is
gonna join us here on the tony michaels
podcast at the bottom of the hour on
tuesdays and he's gonna give us some
kind of story from texas the state that
he's from there's tons of things going
on in texas
because texas paul is texas paul it's
only appropriate that we talk about
texas we'll talk about other things as
well
but the aim is to get some texas news
into the mix here on the podcast
with texas paul texas paul tuesday kathy
says uh tptp tuesdays well that might
that might work
texas torchhum tuesdays margie says
i don't know these are some good ideas i
i don't know i don't know exactly what
we're gonna
what we're gonna call this little
segment here
uh
let's see what else do we have i i don't
know i i
texas tuesdays because there's taco
tuesdays and tech you know me and gabe
love to talk tacos tuesdays gabe is a
taco connoisseur i'd love tacos myself
there's tacos in the news today
not just because it's tuesday
but there's tacos in the news today
because the choco taco the ice cream
taco i think it's blue bunny am i wrong
and the choco taco is being discontinued
which is kind of a sad thing
so
but stick around stick around we will we
will bring in texas paul and we will
bring in gabe sanchez when we return
from the break so stick around don't go
anywhere we will be right back
right after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] em [ __ ] we're back to the tony
michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome welcome back to
the show
thanks for sticking through the break
with us
[Music]
texas paul gabe sanchez
texas texas ball hasn't arrived yet but
i do have gabe sanchez here on the line
with me do you get yourself
oh your cords you plugged your cord in
today
i plugged the cords in man no big deal i
gotta go what did i tell you i said the
soros cables
we had to figure it out but uh we got
there you know your this new room that
you're in this bunker this undisclosed
bunker the sound is fantastic there well
that's what happens when you're uh you
know seven floors below uh oh really you
know the you know like i said i'm in an
undisclosed bunker i am seven floors
below there's probably a bus and a train
and a small child playing a playground
somewhere
i wouldn't know because i can't hear it
oh man the sound there's phenomenal i
mean yeah
there's no echo at all no it's not like
it's not like your grandma's your
grandma's spare bedroom that you brought
right i know hey look hey hey okay you
know
her bedroom is wonderful okay
the shawl that's there on on the dresser
is great okay
no need to no need to harp on no well i
just i i like i like when you broadcast
from your grandma's spirit yeah no i
mean everyone does don't they
i think maybe i think they do i don't
know i don't know texas paul is going to
join us soon about this story from texas
but
there's there's a lot of stuff going on
in texas did you did you happen to catch
the um no moms against greg abbott or
mother's against scary gabba their new
ad it's hilarious it's actually yeah
yeah the one in the uh the doctor's
office right
and it's a perfect example of how you
actually use comedy to send a very very
dark message
right like we talked about this so many
times before
um and it and it just
it
it's frustrating when
certain individuals conservatives nazis
themselves
or just
ex
failed reality tv stars don't understand
what comedy actually is and in this ad
it actually portrays it very very well
and it's not like laugh out loud type
money but it's like holy [ __ ]
the instance the exaggeration in the
actual video
of the government being inside of that
room
is
really telling and that's the hilarious
part of it is when they do the
exaggeration of government being inside
the doctor's office well i mean that's
the thing republicans conservatives
whatever you want to call them you know
nazis nazis you know
um
they have no sense of
timing they have no sense of how to
heighten they have no sense of how to
identify where the button in the joke or
the sketch is like
their joke you know and you know it's
what i identified with alex stein is
these people are not comedians you know
republicans are not going if you if
anyone out there can name me one
funny conservative republican comedian
i will send you some money on venmo not
matt gates venmo money but just you know
a couple bucks
so
because here's the thing they don't
they're unable to find the punch line
there and even and then if you look at
people like matt gates you steal a joke
from someone like george carlin and you
still can't get the punch line right
like how is that even possible only
people
like republicans who are not funny
will steel jokes will will adjust to
their own
and fail in terms of the delivery of
that joke
and so you'll never find a funny person
who is a republican they're never able
to make
a good joke or understand what comedy is
and uh this video portrays it very well
yeah don't you think i mean i mean it
really does a good job of sending a
message even to someone who doesn't
fully understand
what the
what the ramifications i guess you
should say are of this roe v wade being
overturned in a state like texas like
they just when you have a fascist
governor who is willing to take away the
rights of anyone at any opportunity
because that's the difference here
everyone you know
these [ __ ] bone ends especially these
trolls on twitter like oh no
democrats are the fascist it's the
liberals who are the fascists like look
when roe v wade decision came down there
were some states that already had laws
in place yeah they had the tiger ready
people's rights like
immediately in missouri i think it took
seven minutes seven minutes before it
was official that those rights were
taken away
there are not democratic governors
you know
just
just oh they can't wait to take away
people's rights because they're doing
the opposite like right they're trying
to codify these rights right well that
way if there is a national ban that that
there's going to be a
republican fight republicans are are
foaming at the mouth any opportunity
that they have that they can take away
the rights of others right you know that
they can they can take away the rights
that we have been given you know
especially women who have had these
rights
for for decades now to go and say
you thought you had it but you really
don't you know and it's that type of
vile disgusting
behavior actions like whatever you want
to call it from the republicans that
just like they will do whatever they can
to take away the rights that you have
and if you're part of the republican
party and you're over on the corner
right now with them
pointing across the street and laughing
at those who have their rights being
taken away
don't worry because soon enough
you're gonna also be looking at yourself
and being like wait
wait wait hold on i
i j i ha i had that right that you said
i had that right
right and you're gonna find out that
they're gonna find out that they are now
on the receiving end
of the blunt force that is the
republican party in their fastest agenda
well we have we have a special guest
with us and he looks
did you greens did you get did you get
paul agrees i don't know he might have
got i don't know i'm just saying texas
paul might have gotten
an early soros check oh my god it looks
like he's got his soros green screen
here i'm not sure what the hell is going
on he he's been working on the uh the
setup of of his uh studio there so maybe
maybe the soros check did come in yeah
texas paul uh good good morning good
morning
wow that's video patriotic today folks
look at this are you are you in front
are you are you actually
where your background appears or is that
soros george soros paid the green screen
which is god didn't get your checks
no i didn't well i know here i barely
got uh cables to connect me to the
internet where i am right now well
here's the thing here's the thing um
i actually i read a story that george
soros gave a million dollars to bet
o'rourke in texas speaking of texas
stories and i and i tweeted out that we
all of us antifa members are willing to
sacrifice our weekly and daily soros
checks
so that beto aurora can win texas and
that we won't be having chapter meetings
with cookies they will be without antifa
cookies this time because we just can't
afford because we had to give up our
paychecks for beto to have a paycheck
not necessary not necessary at all betto
is rocking it setting records 27.6
million dollars in his last reporting
and that's before the soros check so
that's we're doing great folks
down
i
i love this this background i can't i
can't help but
gabe you you're way you know i know
you're he's got me beater wait it gets
better
he's he's gonna do something better here
he says yeah there we go turn the lights
on ah
wow i saw the light i saw the light so
texas paul we're we're going to do these
tuesday things we're trying to figure
out what we're going to call this thing
some people like uh texas texas tuesday
or texas paul tuesday there's a lot of
different things someone even said tp
tuesdays which ah i don't know about
that but here
but here here's what here's what i'll
say is that there is a story from texas
and i think that's what we want to do on
tuesdays is because there's so much
stuff going on in texas with your
governor with this race for the governor
but also some of the things that they're
that the fascist
um not just the governor but the
legislators also doing where they're
trying to turn back rights they're
trying to make sure anyone and everyone
can get a firearm to kill and slaughter
19 children and two teachers but tell me
about this story that we were uh looking
at this morning i haven't had a chance
to read it now did you get a chance to
go over this story about um how roe
is affecting
actual actual families in texas right
now it's it's a thing that is
significantly hurting families you know
the pro-family party you know
you know
i i've got to be honest with you it's
really heartbreaking it kind of chokes
me up a little bit every time i talk
about it you know you've got people out
there that
these pastors and activists they have no
idea what they're doing
they don't
they get passionate about something and
a lot of them are just grifters want to
griff money from church people and
and
they they they get on these causes and
they have no idea what they're doing
you know we had a woman down here named
marlena stell
that had to carry a dead
fetus for two
weeks
and she had to be told
three times three separate times
no doctor would do a dnc for her down
here
because of these crazy ass laws because
the they're really going after doctors
down here who are trying to provide
medical care she had a dead fetus they
knew from the ultrasound the doctor
refused to do the dnc on her
until she got
a subsequent
sonogram
she wouldn't got a second sonogram had
to be told from another doctor
yes your baby's dead
went back to the first doctor the doctor
said i'm sorry i i just got a letter
from the state threatening me
yeah i can't do it i can't you're gonna
have to get another confirming
sonogram
she had to go out for a third sonogram
and we're talking about costs here time
time away from work before you even get
into
the psychological trauma
of being told and these are the invasive
sonograms guys these are not the jelly
on the belly this is the one this is
really and and i hate to be
crude
but let's be real about it okay this
woman had to have a wand shoved in her
vagina
three
frickin times
because of greg abbott
because of greg abbott and be told
three separate times that she
her
fetus had died
and on top of that what they don't
understand is
these dnc's are medically necessary at
that point
had she developed an infection which is
usually what happens when a fetus dies
you know we're talking about necrotic
flesh and stuff inside a woman
to be as
harsh about it as i can they develop
infections and it can actually sterilize
them
the infection spreads to their fallopian
tubes to their egg to their
ovaries and it's
this is not just a matter of
hey we don't like abortions this is a
matter of you are sterilizing women with
this law
and it's just insane i think that's i
think that's a great point because you
think the pro-life pro family you know
all the nonsense they spew would want a
woman to have an opportunity to have a
safe medical procedure that would allow
her to have more children
not not less more children if that's the
way their thought process is but paul
don't you agree that this is not about
abortion it's it's not what it's about
that's never what this has been about
it's always been a been about taking the
rights and liberty away from women
taking their bodily autonomy away from
them and the next step is to take their
vote away so they can't they can't do
anything about uh voting in politicians
that will help them with their bodily
autonomy and make sure that the
government stays out of that out of that
doctor's office
well you're absolutely right with that
you're absolutely right with that it you
know they're ignorant bastards and don't
know what they're doing they really do
they don't know what they're doing with
these laws
but you know i just did a
i do videos every day about different
candidates and how horrible they are
we just had a lieutenant governor up in
minnesota talking about um
you know abortions are letting women
have careers
abortions are letting you made a joke
about women driving
you know the everything they do going
after griswold v connecticut they want
to take away contraception it and it's
not just about the morning after pill
you know we just had a
a a couple people down here in walgreens
[ __ ] walgreens
refused to sell a couple a married
couple
condoms
because her religious beliefs didn't
allow her to do that well i'm sorry
you know if if your religious beliefs
don't allow you to consume alcohol or
anything like that don't get a job as a
wine tester
you know don't
if your religious beliefs won't allow
you to sell what walgreens sells don't
get a damn job at walgreens
go somewhere else
you know this is ridiculous
it's getting ins insanely stupid down
here these sons of [ __ ] have no idea
what they're doing and what they're
unleashing on the
texas and american people and the worst
part of it is when greg abbott does
something down here well his competitor
you know desantis and everybody else
that wants to run for president well
they've got to jump on the bandwagon so
that you know in in these upcoming
presidential primaries in 2024 when the
debates happened they could all say oh
well yeah i was that [ __ ] radical too
right
it's it's it's like a cancer spreading
across the country you know i love to
talk about texas topics with you but
this is spreading like
cancer well they can't even get they
can't even get their story straight
because you've got uh you know marsha
blackburn uh
who
what last within the last two months she
was saying that the only people who
could get contraception were married
couples right she was saying that the
sanctity of marriage would allow you
to have the ability to purchase
contraception whether it's the
uh it's it's taking um
or you know condoms or it's uh taking
birth control or whatever it might be
like they can't get their story straight
at one point it's saying that married
couples can have it now it's saying that
no one can have it then it's gonna be
something that's even more aggressive
like at each point you're you are so on
the money paul where it's talking about
all of these people who are in
leadership positions are trying to say
well that person just they move the line
forward you know everyone keeps moving
the goal post and they're going to keep
moving it further and further and
further and further and to a certain
point where you're going to say well
there's no rights left no one can do
anything not even the people that made
those laws will have any rights left for
them
right like you're wrongly bad aspect
you're wrong about that aspect and this
is where i did that video about cleaning
up your own backyard
okay
i will not have problems
i am a comfortably
financially middle-aged white guy
you know some people say oh but [ __ ]
them
i'm not gonna have a
you know who's going to have a problem
every woman in this country is going to
have a problem because if you listen to
their rhetoric i mean i go through
candidate after candidate after
candidate and i will tell you they all
say the same thing
back in the kitchen
you know in texas now in texas
judges
not not this the legislature didn't do
this this is just judges on their own
acting you talk about an out-of-control
branch of government judges on their own
will not finalize divorces
if you're pregnant
they won't do it
they won't do it well they're doing it
they're doing the same thing in missouri
yeah they're doing it here too um i i
mean
we had jd vancouver violent i don't care
if it's a violent marriage they will not
finalize it until the baby hits the
ground what the other dance
said the other day and he's he's a
republican fascist trump-backed uh
candidate in ohio who's
who's losing badly because he's such a
[ __ ] phony but he he was he was
caught in an interview from a while back
saying uh well there shouldn't be
divorce at all even in a violent
marriage there shouldn't be divorce
right [ __ ] divorce i mean this is
talking to kids tony right he's talking
to kids in a christian high school first
of all why are you talking to kids about
divorce
you know why why is jd vance talking to
kids about divorce talk about the wrong
source to the wrong audience right then
he said exactly what you said you know
some marriages are unhappy some
marriages are violent you don't just run
out and get a divorce
[ __ ]
[ __ ] but then then the divorce in a
violent marriage you you well they they
loved it i i you know obviously you know
they they come they come for the
liberals and the people on the left who
say you guys are indoctrinating our
children crt this and this and that i
have my own insecurities and and i'm
projecting on my own child and whatever
the issue might be
but if you look time and time again you
look at matt gates giving a misogynistic
speech at the student action summit in
front of a bunch of teenagers students
kids you look it's a sex trafficker
right it's like why is this guide
allowed in a group full of kids right
just a room full of teenagers seems to
be obviously their target demographic
and they're okay with it and they won't
denounce his behavior or the nazis
outside or whatever because they're fine
with it they want to get them in young
just like marjorie taylor green said
when she was meeting with nick fuentes
group right then you have um
you have
every opportunity that they can get
along the way is to get them in young
you've got jd vance talking to students
right like at any point they can get
them in young and flip the switch so
that they now believe what the
republican party says is to be truth and
100 valid in the in the you know god's
given truth then they will go forward
with it but yes it is you know it's
easier to turn a young mind than it is
an older mind who has had years of
experience and so they'll keep going
they'll keep pushing why i'll tell you
that i think there's things that are
turning minds out there and me and gabe
were talking about this texas paul
before we brought you in is that we try
sometimes to use comedy and satire to
get people to think a certain way about
a subject right and um
mothers against greg abbott have had a
few good ads but this last ad that they
just released it it it really gives you
a sense
of how exaggerated it is but how real it
is that governor greg abbott is inside
the doctor's office when a woman is
trying to make a decision which at this
point in texas she does not have and
this ad portrays it so well let me play
it here uh and then we'll talk about it
on the other side
thank you for your patience
there's no easy way to say this but your
baby has a catastrophic brain
abnormality
what does that mean
it means that parts of her brain didn't
form
your daughter
if she is to survive will live only a
matter of hours after birth
during that time she will experience a
multitude of seizures and ultimately
aspirate on her own bodily fluids
she will suffer
a decision will need to be made on
termination
i wish i could tell you what to do
but there is only one person who can
make this choice
how much time do i have and that person
is greg
greg
who the [ __ ] is greg yeah let me just
give him a call
[Music]
hey greg
dr robinson here
listen i've got a pregnancy that could
yes
but i think this one is the
yes okay
sure
sure
okay i'll let them know
[Music]
yeah that's gonna be a no best of luck
to you
who the [ __ ] is greg well [ __ ] greg yeah
that's what i say [ __ ] greg abbott you
know
many times at protests [ __ ] greg abbott
right telling me well that that video
because the part where he goes to the
telephone is absolutely
hilarious but in reality as exaggerated
as that may seem that there's a phone
with greg abbott's picture on it and
it's a direct line to the governor's
desk
i almost bet that there are republicans
sitting in legislators in elected office
right now that would love
would love to be able to have to have a
doctor call them first to tell them what
the [ __ ] care they can and cannot give
to a woman right i always bet that that
exaggeration is almost real well you
look at this right you look at this
example right with comedy you always
want to heighten you want to always take
it to a level that is above reality and
right now obviously again base reality
is like 15 maybe 20 and heightening it
would go to like 25 30 which normally
would be like let's heighten it to a 10
but thanks to trump and all these
fascists we no longer live in that type
of reality
but yeah they look at this
and right now today you're like that is
a funny play on the situation right it's
a direct line phone boom got greg abbott
right on the line but like you said
you will look at this and say
how long until they say
that's actually a pretty good idea we
should have direct lines to greg abbott
when we need to make these very
important issues about someone else's
life you know because that's really what
they want right don't you think texas
paul that's what they want is they want
to live inside everyone else's life and
tell them what the [ __ ] to do real big
government actual big government
well let me tell you something it's not
a [ __ ] exaggeration it's not and this
is what's got me so god damn mad about
this whole [ __ ] situation is that
yeah it's not a telephone but they're
already sending threatening [ __ ]
letters to these doctors they are
already
doing this this is not something that's
that's hyperbole
manga didn't make this ad mothers
against greg abbott didn't make this ad
because they thought it might happen
they made this ad because that's [ __ ]
reality here in texas
every ob gyn is getting a threatening
[ __ ] letter from the state saying
these are the guidelines we've set out
if you break them we will come after you
and gives a a list of threats including
we will take your license we will sue
you we will jail you
this is [ __ ] reality people this i
mean it's funny sure yeah it's a it's a
funny ad but it's not funny because this
is really going on manga didn't make
this ad like i said to just say this
might happen this is [ __ ] happening
right well and that's enraging and
that's and that's the real thrust of the
comedy here is to get someone to pay
attention because i really do believe
that there's folks out there that were
like yeah overturn road that'll be great
it'll save the children and and then but
they do not realize because they're
they're let's face it they're white
dudes they're [ __ ] white dudes
they're [ __ ] white dudes they don't
know anything about [ __ ] women's
healthcare they don't know anything
about a [ __ ] pregnancy they they
couldn't probably point out a goddamn
vagina if it was on a [ __ ] map right
i'm telling you these [ __ ] people
have no clue what they're talking about
they just was a representative who was
under the impression that if you
swallowed a camera they would be able to
see the pregnancy what had to be what
the what the [ __ ] who i i will i will
find the video right now but yes there
was a general there was a representative
i think was on a little more local state
level and he asked the question
camera to see it and then they were like
sir the stomach is not what it was
where the women are [ __ ] babies out
well this is what's happening you have
these men who know nothing about the
female anatomy or how the body works and
are saying that they should be making
the rules for them but yeah i will crazy
worse than that guys it's worse than
that are you guys old enough to know who
terry shivo was
yeah okay
this woman's brain
she had been in a coma so long you know
you're not the reason these coma scare
doctors is because
there are physical deteriorations that
occur including your brain turns to
pudding after a while and the doctors
knew terry shivo
heard there was nothing left of her
brain the doctors knew it but you had
these [ __ ] con artists out there
these [ __ ] hucksters that were saying
send me money click the link
click the link send me money i'm
fighting to keep this woman alive
they're trying to murder her it's the
same [ __ ] car and artists that are
doing the same thing here these are not
pastors that and and and and priests
with moral objections leading this [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] con artists they're
lying to people that look like me who
want to be holier than now that have no
[ __ ] sense of where their lane is
they're
suffering from dunning-kruger syndrome
to the extreme
and and they're willing to to
just try to empower themselves over
human beings and second-guess doctors
that know what the hell they're doing
because hey they've been told over and
over again by the con artists including
[ __ ] mango mussolini the top con
artist of them all telling them
scientists don't know [ __ ] doctors don't
know [ __ ]
you
the guy that operates the goddamn
bulldozer or drives the truck you know
as much about health care you've got
common sense
[ __ ]
[ __ ] these people
well i i agree and you called
don the khan the king of khans i think
you called him there um i actually the
other day everyone liked it i don't know
maybe we should go back to it i i called
it i called him the pied piper of
[ __ ]
um that's perfect
every everyone i i don't know where that
came from but i i called him the pied
piper of dumb [ __ ] and it and it stuck
here is here's a video the video gave
that you sent
um
this is uh where where is this again
uh this i have to look up a sec but this
is a representative in idaho idaho idaho
veto
barbara
barbarelli maybe is his name i told you
this is nationwide spreading like a
cancer
so let's listen
to how he thinks um stomachs
are connected to the uterus it's very
weird
can this same procedure then be done
in a pregnancy
following swallowing a camera and oh
[ __ ] helping the doctor determine what
the situation is with the mr chairman oh
my god so he's asking someone i see what
you're saying it's worse than i thought
it was yeah like it's way worse than i
thought it was because they're talking
about a procedure for which clearly is
the digestive system right before this
clip and he's like well could this be
done with the break like he's already
been told that it the camera goes you
know and your digesters oh jesus this
guy what the [ __ ] chairman of
representative
uh it cannot be done in pregnancy simply
because when you swallow a pill it would
not end up in the vagina
[Laughter]
well i mean i guess i guess you just got
to put it to him simple right like right
i don't like that
these are the people these are the
people that are making rules like they
on the record are asking these questions
and the people who are there answering
them like
what the [ __ ]
are you guys doing
like that's that is what we that is the
reality we live in and it is like like
paul said it is [ __ ] spreading
everywhere
guys
okay women
this is where it's your fault
if this guy had gotten laid once in his
life
he would [ __ ] know
that they are not connected but see i i
but see i don't actually believe that
either paul i don't believe that just
because these [ __ ] idiots
because these people these these are
insidious people they're doing insidious
things just like matt getz is accused of
sex trafficking minors and he goes out
at this sas this turning point usa nazi
rally this bigotry bonanza
and it's just
and he's able to talk to teenagers but i
mean i would imagine that this guy that
this guy
has has looked at a lot of pictures and
a lot of videos of a vagina and he just
made a complete fool of himself because
he knows nothing more than what he wants
what he wants out of that genitalia not
what what what the person who has it
wants or what they need or the medical
care that they need he doesn't give a
[ __ ] and that is the actual point here
is these [ __ ] don't care about
anyone but their goddamn cells and like
we were saying earlier
paul
me and you ah we're we're good we got
beards we're white
we look white we sound white well we're
we're good to go we're good to go
and everyone well
yeah well
not just because of that but yeah right
right yeah yeah but it depends 50 of the
time i might be okay i might not be okay
but right right right right as long as
well you know it happens it happens but
but that's but that's the problem here
is that
we have a democracy and we have to count
on this democracy to deliver rights and
liberty to people and liberty is the
actual key here to get liberty to
everyone that is the actual goal now it
is hard it is difficult equality and
equity is a very tough thing to achieve
for every single person and every single
facet that you want them to achieve it
it because it is democracy and there are
compromises but at the same time you if
you are pro-democracy out there which i
know our audiences are now texas paul
and ours here at the tony michaels
podcast you have to engage in the ballot
you have to go vote you have to do these
things and it's not just about marking
your ballot you have to see if you can
register people if you're good at that
jesus if you are good at text messaging
or talking to people on the phone grab a
phone phone bank with a candidate that
you like or even in another state go
phone bank for a pro democracy candidate
because that's the thing we have to do
is to talk to people we know about these
things show them that mothers for greg
abbott ad show them that maybe it'll
trigger something oh wait
is that really what it means yes that's
exactly what it means representative who
thinks you swallow a [ __ ] camera and
it ends up in your vagina like liter
this guy does have no he has no clue he
had no clue and this son of a [ __ ] is
sitting there making laws and that is
the point is we cannot discount
us engaging in the ballot us engaging in
our democracy to advance it forward and
that is what we have failed we have
failed in this country to engage in our
democracy to know these things listen to
a goddamn woman listen to her when she's
telling you about medical procedures
that are abortion procedures
listen to them they know they have had
these procedures it's there
right
they have had to think about these
procedures listen to them dummy open up
your ears um and there's a ton of
examples uh in your state of beto aurora
changing some of these republicans minds
just by the things that he says and and
trying to because he is he is highly
engaged uh on the campaign trail i think
that's why beto is doing so well i think
that's i think that's why he has such a
chance um in the state of texas is he's
so engaged in that democracy and his
campaign and his followers and his
people that he has working so hard for
democracy there they're pro-democracy
they're engaged i know a ton of the
midas mighty are behind beto and working
hard for him there and and paul you're a
minus mighty face i hope you're setting
up that clip of him talking to that
republican because that was
a master class on how to talk to
republicans i really hope you guys have
that clip of beto well i can get any
clip you want
this woman had been a lifelong
republican always voted republican came
to listen to beto
she asked him a question about
immigration and he just barely bonds
that thing right out of the frickin park
man this i mean it was a master class if
you're a politician on how to talk to
republicans and how to win was that was
that in midland was that in midland
i believe so
i got here from midland texas this is
off of bedo's account um here it is tell
me yeah that's it okay here we go i was
born a republican i've never voted
democrat in all my life i was going for
the other guy i'm not gonna lie
but i came here to hear your point of
views what do you plan
to do about the porter about the
millions of people that are coming in to
the united states as you know i live in
el paso amy and i are raising our three
kids on the u.s mexico border here's how
i feel this is what i'm going to do as
governor if you want to come to this
country you want to join a family member
you want to work a job you want to claim
asylum or seek refuge we want you to be
able to do that but you have to do that
legally you have to do that in an
orderly fashion and we're going to make
sure that we honor the laws on our side
you know the current governor on the eve
of that el paso shooting where 23 of my
neighbors lost their lives sent out a
mailer talking about an invasion asking
texans to defend themselves
and take matters into their own hands
what if texas elected a governor who
would work on rewriting our immigration
laws to match our ideals and our values
our necessities and the reality that we
see what if we had a governor who wasn't
trying to scare you about people coming
over here to get it so let's make sure
that we do the right thing
safe legal orderly and we rewrite our
laws to reflect our values thank you for
coming here afterwards i'm going to ask
you how i did and whether we can count
on your vote okay thank you but no
pressure all right i'm looking for mr
greg abbott i voted for trump for
president
um
never in my life have i voted never have
i come never but i really like what i
heard from
mr rorke if he's going to protect
our system if he's going to protect the
borders he's going to protect our
children me and my family will
so there you have it there you have it
um exactly what paul was talking about
he did such a good job and the only
reason why is because
he just he's a [ __ ] human being that
o'rourke's a human being notice how he
personalized it in the beginning where
he's like hey i live on a border town i
raised my family on a border town and we
need to stop scaring people into
believing that this is a scary thing if
we just
use our [ __ ] brains and we elect
people who who actually want to enact
policy
want to do good policy with actual
ideals then we won't have these [ __ ]
problems we won't have these problems
and yes
again democracy is not perfect it's
difficult it's hard and beto shows you
how hard it is when he goes before a
crowd and someone who says they voted
republican their entire life and he just
says exactly how he feels to to make
them to make them see hey i'm not your
enemy i'm not your enemy i'm a fellow
texan i live in el paso i'm an american
and i don't want to demonize anyone who
wants to come here to to to be an
american or to be in this country
but we have to have policies in place
where we're not scaring just the people
coming coming here but the people who
are here from the people coming here
this [ __ ] racist this thin veil
racist this [ __ ] where where for for
years we've we've scared people about
the word migrant it's it's [ __ ]
ridiculous and i think beto does a
fantastic job there and i think
in texas there's going to be more of
that and greg abbott is in big big
[ __ ] trouble what do you say
paul
well i think that when they overturned
roe v wade the dog caught the bumper got
stuck and is getting drug down the road
and getting mangled
i tell you
that is the only silver lining to this
horrific situation is that republicans
can no longer
live behind that lie uh well we're
they're not really gonna do that they're
not you know how many years did we hear
them say we wanted to overturn roe v
wade and guys like you and me were
screaming they're gonna do it if you
give them the chance they're gonna do it
and people were like nah it's settled a
lot it's not no they really are going to
do these things they want to do these
things and i'll tell you it's been i've
had two conversations one i posted
um
it was a woman i was coming out of sam's
helping my wife do some grocery shopping
and
i hear somebody screaming my name texas
paul texas paul and i'm looking around
the parking lot what the hell and then i
see this woman in a car
hanging out her window waving at me and
i walked over and i talked to her turns
out she's voted republican
up until about three years ago
then she started hearing me
and then i introduced her to midas and
she's like wow
i never heard anybody in this area talk
this way before
so yeah
saying it
means it just reaffirmed to me that we
need to be saying this stuff that's
right because there are people out there
that are hearing this and and then i had
a felon
get in touch with me a guy that
was a felon went up to huntsville
did his time got out he's straightened
his life out he's got a job and he's
like you know i can't vote
i can't i can't vote i'm not and i can't
register i can't do anything i said you
know and he said i'm barely making ends
meet so i don't really have time to take
off of work
um you know
to to do any kind of
long-term
uh volunteering and whatnot he said but
you know what i talked to my mom and my
mom listens to you guys and you know
what she got me to do
i'm now part of the church pool
on election day i'm driving women
to the polls
i'm delivering people to the polls
that's what i'm gonna do
this guy can't be part of the process
because he [ __ ] up in his life
but he's turned it around
and he's going to be driving people to
the polls and getting them to allowing
other people to vote i'm telling you we
reach people right well and that and
that is what everyone should do everyone
should engage in the ballot just like
paul is talking about uh this this
fellow who who is engaging in the ballot
the way that he can and that's what
everyone should be doing we yell and
scream every day and paul you make a ton
of videos uh for the midas touch network
over there on youtube and go follow if
you're not already you're missing out go
follow the minus touch network uh
channel over on youtube and also follow
us the tony michaels podcaster on
youtube and paul paul you have a youtube
channel now um how how is that going
should people follow you there on
twitter where should they follow yet
you know
i i've
been trying to expand my social media on
all fronts well you're doing the green
screen i mean hell yeah you're putting
gabe to shame here with the green screen
hey gabe inspired me actually it wasn't
is that what it was
yeah he did oh thank you he was just
popping up backgrounds and i was like
you did that thing with the white house
the other day i was like
i gotta be able to do that
[Laughter]
that was amazing gabe you impressed the
[ __ ] out of me man you're going thank
you you're smart you're technically
proficient
don't give him two months don't give him
too much of an ego boost for crying out
loud ball
[ __ ] i'm trying to adopt him man
i know i
didn't you hear him he said i've got a
i've got a place in his family now that
was on the that was during the hearing
or was that last week tuesday i i don't
know it all gets completed that might
have been last week tuesday but dave
before you say yes just remember you're
the guy i'll be calling hey man i can't
get my phone to work how do i do that
that i call him all the time asking him
and he's like okay grandpa i'm like i
don't know what that does
sometimes sometimes at texas paul he'll
send me something he'll say something
about some type of technology that we're
trying to figure out i'm trying to
figure out and and i s and i always text
him back speak hillbilly like you're not
you're you're talking way above
my my hillbilly speak hillbilly parent
down a bit jesus christ but the texas
paul thanks for joining us
everyone follow texas paul on twitter
your twitter account's blown up but go
go follow paul there and also follow him
on tic tac where else do you get
see that paul tx890 right there uh-huh
that is on the vast majority of almost i
was lucky enough to capture that
on the
tick tock twitter uh instagram
uh it's either paul it's either texas
paul or paul tx890 and yeah follow me on
youtube i'm starting to put more out on
youtube i've been focusing on instagram
right now because i really want to get
over that 10 000 mark on instagram so
that i can uh share my videos directly
to instagram and i'd have to go through
the whole stories process where you do
the little sticker and you know
i'm expanding out there man i'd i've
neglected my social media
um but thank god my granddaughter came
to me one day and said hey look this is
tip top take a look at this you can yell
all the [ __ ] that you want to yell at me
yell it at other people
yell it into a camera and publish it
thank you texas paul for joining us come
back next tuesday uh i know there'll be
more stories from texas and all around
the country of how how these fascists
are affecting the country and how how uh
your audience should stay vigilant so
come back next tuesday we appreciate
having you here
i always enjoy being here guys y'all
doing an amazing job and and tony i want
to say it again you and gabe
on the january 6 hearings were
incredible
stay tuned incredible job in seeing that
thank you and and and it really made
it super easy being on the panel how
many views did we have total gabe we
figured that up the other day now
it's still picking up i think it's one
like 1.7 million views we have
throughout youtube that was totally for
all the eight hearings yeah that was the
total that that's pretty big that's a
big number paul that's a big number it
was a great success and and everyone
stay tuned because texas paul will join
us next tuesday but he'll also join us
in those hearings in september speaking
of january 6th select hearings so paul
thank you very much we'll see you next
week my friend have a great week we'll
talk to you soon great to see you guys
again everybody everyone everyone stick
around we'll be right back right after
this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow
so we can circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the
live love loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day ears
tammy
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking to the break
texas paul tuesday tuesday with texas
fall
tuesday in texas i don't know where
we're gonna go we're going to we're
going to figure out something
maybe
make a graphic or something you know
really do it up well i mean gabe he's
really beating you on the uh on the old
green screen i know
this is what happened you know it's like
i i bring my show down to a bunker seven
floors below
the surface and he heightens his show up
with the green screen
he's really he's really good i think the
issue is you know like because i'm in a
bunker i'm not getting the checks as
quickly as possible oh is that what it
is like the ground level
so i see that's what's happening i do i
don't i don't do direct deposit i get i
just i still do the physical mail checks
you know oh oh it's so it's so it
doesn't you don't do the uh the ach no
you're still you're still getting them
um snail mailed something about the
nostalgia having a paper check you know
okay well um
speaking of uh uh
people who believe george soros sends
checks um
you you've seen this uh alison steinberg
yeah she she's always complaining about
stuff oh my god she's rocking around she
she claims to love san diego on her
social media and she's walking around
talking about how people have colored
hair and [ __ ] in san diego like oh my
god like if ethan schmidt
if ethan schmidt
was
a girl not act like a little girl but he
was a woman and this is this is like him
like you know what i mean like they
would be no no go to each other i'm not
trying to set up alice in an ethan or
anything but they would be
not perfect they might come from the
same like family you know well i mean
even better totally even better yeah but
even better
if everyone knows the story is that oan
um not only got their asses kicked off
at d but got their ass kicked off
verizon um
recently i think the only cable news
uh platform that they're on is somewhere
in alaska or some [ __ ] yeah they have
nowhere other than uh
just online to pretty much post their
stuff right i think there's lots of
stuff yeah there's a few streaming
places where you can still find them
right now
and they're really they're suffering
because of it she almost cries in this
video this is yeah she's getting really
worked up about this she really loves
his job she really loves this job of
disinformation right because she's
really good at disinformation like she's
super good at lying and super good at
just being a total [ __ ] troll like
just like alex stein type [ __ ] right
yeah but here's the thing is that
the reason why i think this is
irrelevant because some people like oh
tony why is this rolling it's relevant
because
this is exactly what democracy does to
these [ __ ]
liberalism and liberal democracy this is
what it does to these fascist [ __ ]
that's why they hate it so much they
hate liberalism because it [ __ ] it's
free market it's liberty it's freedom
it's about rights and they don't want
you to have them they want to be able to
shove their [ __ ] down your throat
well they they don't like things being
regulated they don't like any sort of
checks and balances so that's besides
what they want to regulate right exactly
they're like look look we don't want
regulation on you know our free market
capitalism we don't want regulation on
this industry the the in you know epa we
want to take regulations away we want to
do this you want to do that you know
elections we want to do whatever we want
so you know when all of a sudden they
have to receive
the actual
other side of it which is hey we're
going to regulate you and that is done
by a private company that decides that
they don't want to carry you anymore for
whatever the reason may be right yes
they kicked you out
and you're now saying this isn't fair
i'm go
i'm gonna get kicked off the air and no
one's gonna listen to what i have to say
anymore
i don't [ __ ] care this is what
happens well here's you also have a
[ __ ] defamation lawsuit so
right and not to mention remember that
oan also settled
for
the uh
uh the lawsuit against um
uh the the the georgia poll worker and
her mother that was one of the lawsuits
they also have like i i think literally
have like some odd million
uh
maybe one million or a little bit more
than a million
cases
against them right now and that was the
only one that they had uh resolved in
march of 2022
uh ruby freeman and um
and uh i'm blanking on her name right
now the poll worker
but anyway oh yeah that was the one case
that they settled and they still have
the dominion one and they have all of
these other lawsuits that are against
them right now well let's listen to
allison
cry moga tears because that's the
satisfaction here that's what i want
everyone to see is the fruits of your
labor in participating in your democracy
here is the fruit of your labor
meanwhile everyone here at one america
news one of the last actual remaining
real and credible news sources exist the
journalists who report on facts
checkmark
even more infuriating our network as a
whole is being relentlessly targeted as
tv providers continue to try to erase us
from existence it began earlier this
year when at t dropped us and now just
last week verizon announced that they
will be doing the scene
but despite the massive blow to everyone
here at one america news
meanwhile
what a trunt that that sucks that sucks
like if they were really good about what
they did if they really had actual
credibility to their name they wouldn't
only have uh less than a handful or so
of sources of income
to make sure that they stayed afloat you
had att which was like 90 million
dollars that was helping fund this uh
pro right fascist agenda on tv
like she's getting upset the fact that
now they're like oh i can't spread the
propaganda i can't you know spread the
fascist agenda i can't do this i can't
do that
well i'm sorry but
right so
go spread it somewhere else right if
people really thought that you were
credible that i'm sure you won't have
any issue getting hired at some other uh
news source or publication which i'm
sure she probably will get hired
somewhere
but like the the crying
the whining the complaining
we're one of the last credible news
sources out there you have to allow us
to pump our propaganda [ __ ]
is this [ __ ]
with that [ __ ] so here here's another
here's another trader news network that
we need to work on with our pro
democracy muscles
no no i think they propped him up here
and there's someone is this like a tupac
hologram right now right when they're
moving they're moving his mouth this is
literally literally they are they are
not hiding their nazi here
it's an america first agenda summit in
washington dc now this is significant
agenda is very big there right
agenda well they didn't want the america
they don't want to be like nazi agenda
like right right agenda is like nazi
agenda right right right so
this event is supposed to be i don't
know
how many of these [ __ ] things
they have this is what i've been saying
we actually need to have event after
event after event like this we need to
start having pro-democracy events like
this i know people would go to it i know
people would participate i know people
would listen to people speak who are
pro-democracy we need to start [ __ ]
combating these [ __ ] well i had
a there are a ton of there were a ton of
people that were asking me when i shared
the matt gates video and also the ted
cruz video from this weekend people kept
asking me like does
does the left have something like this
no we need to we need to we only have
one and it's literally called the dnc
right and when we're like about to elect
a president like that's the biggest
thing that we have right these
[ __ ] are having every weekend
everybody have intros and videos and
lights and smoke and like yeah it's
cringe worthy but man they [ __ ] let's
do it let's do the cringe let's do that
while we do the cringe here we're not
we're not scared of it hell we'll we'll
we'll put on the events where you just
contact me tony michael's podcast and
we'll try to i don't know maybe we'll
have to build the team or something gabe
can do some ai or something i don't know
well here's the thing is that
this event here is in washington dc and
at this event trump's supposed to speak
i believe today um at this event this is
the first time he has come back to
washington oh that's right yeah back to
dc since the election or since since
right yeah right since he since he flew
away on his helicopter uh with his tail
between his legs now here's the
significance of this clip
not just that trump's going to be
speaking at this event
but newt gingrich here is speaking about
schedule f
um the ability to actually gut the
federal government and install a fascist
government this is exactly their plan
now listen to what he says he doesn't
say it outright because newt gingrich is
from the old guard where you're not
overtly fascist and overtly nazi
like marjorie taylor green loren bobert
and donald trump he's from the old guard
where you kind of you know
you gotta you gotta thin veil it with
conservatism right and be a phony let's
listen because of the experience of the
four years under president trump
we have a seasoned enough cadre
that if we work at it methodically
we can actually have an enormous impact
on profoundly reshaping the federal
government and i think in that sense
that the american first policy institute
is very important i think this agenda is
a very good starting point
and i want to emphasize that concept
starting point
so he's like yeah nazis are great and
this is a great starting point for
mineconf but we want to go way further
than this yeah and if you notice he
dances around the word schedule f he
dances around
absolutely destroying the federal
government here's the thing
here's the thing this is why donald
trump and the republicans do not want
him to be president they want someone
more competent to be present and here's
why is because he absolutely would not
do the work to staff the federal
government now this schedule f thing is
kind of scary right yeah just how it's
written the executive order why they can
fire the federal employees but every
single presidency that's why these
elections [ __ ] matter not just for
the presidency but for the legislator
and the senate folks is because these
administrations get to install
their their likeness inside the
government what donald trump did and
what we have the opportunity to do
in the coming years in every single
election if we just participate in our
democracy and engage in our ballot and
use strategic outrage to do it
donald trump absolutely decimated the
federal government
he he
the federal government is almost not
there's places where it was existing
that it's non-existent we can rebuild
back those in a pro-democracy image
right and we can use the tools that
donald trump gave us to do that [ __ ]
them [ __ ] them [ __ ] them [ __ ] them if
that's what they want then we should
actually use the [ __ ] that they try
to pull to install a pro-democracy
government and protect the people in
this country from people like this
[ __ ] walking dead body newt gingrich
who
i i can't even believe that we still
give a microphone to some [ __ ] schlub
who had to resign a speaker of the house
in the 1990s why in the [ __ ] are we
still doing this [ __ ] where he's then
bailing this fascism and holding up mind
mineconf basically yeah and saying we
definitely want to go a lot further than
this i mean like you know target
demographic is clearly older people
right so it's like you know you
you gotta have a you know fascism light
for those people who were like not
really ready to
to to pull pull it out like that so i
think for all the new people like oh
yeah this is great like i can rely on
these other people to speak but they're
like okay we need someone who might kind
of want to like
uh soften the blow you know for these
people to eventually be like yeah
fascism is cool this is great we should
do this
and so newt gingrich i think uh you know
as the idiot as he is
uh probably goes for that older group
you know
the people who are still alive and still
voting
speaking of fascist fighting fascists
we watched yesterday matt gets steal a
line from george garland
which number one why in the [ __ ] is this
alleged child sex trafficker going to a
student conference anywhere on the face
of the earth what in the [ __ ] is wrong
with these people do they not understand
imagery at all now the second thing here
is that is that in the speech he's he's
really
he's really saying the opposite thing
that he thinks he's saying he's like oh
all these women who are anti-abortion
are ugly and fat and blah blah blah and
that's why they want abortion like what
that
that is the opposite of what you the
joke you told that you [ __ ] dummy
but you're in this these are the same
these are the same people you know that
i've
these are the same people that uh
uh oh that's soros internet that's soros
internet
man that that that you need to switch to
the ach if you switch to the ach gabe
and get your soros check out him yeah i
know i know i know but what i was what i
was saying was they're all the same in
the sense that like they
they will
um
uh you know say how women are are ugly
and you know they're this and they're
that and all sorts of just denigrating
or like insulting terms against women
right because they're the man and they
know what's right
but like i said in the show last week
all of these guys are the same they go
to a bar they go to you know hit on a
woman or go talk to her the woman says
nope yeah thank you out of here with
that [ __ ] and then they go then they go
to their friends who goes oh she's a
[ __ ] lesbian dude she didn't like it
right you know
no it's because you're an [ __ ] and
you're a douche and she has better
higher standards than lowering herself
to some guy who's probably uh you know
guilty of sex trafficking so all of
these guys who get rejected
then take it out on women
to say like oh i'm god's gift
and you didn't want me that means
there's something wrong with you right
and that's what matt gates is trying to
do in this type of language and rhetoric
as well as all these other people
they're the ones who get [ __ ]
rejected so they try to spin it and they
go oh no no it's just like someone who
says i didn't i'm not fired i quit right
it's like oh i didn't get rejected uh no
i rejected you right right and so it's
it's people like this and men like this
who can't fire me i quit right exactly
it's the whole like i'm gonna re
restate what the narrative was i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm a revisionist to what
actually happened it's like no failure
you got denied
and now your butt hurt and you're trying
to make yourself seem cooler and uh you
know
bigger and stronger than you actually
are right well speaking speaking of
revision and the truth here we have mark
short here on the screen and he's gonna
he's gonna react to the maghetz which is
this is [ __ ] hilarious but the
significance uh though of mark short in
the news right now is mark short
actually
gabe he went and he was deposed by a
grand jury a criminal grand jury
from the justice department for the
january 6 insurrection and everyone out
there who is doubting that the
department of justice is doing anything
they are at the president's chief of
staff
at this point that's who they're
deposing is that vice president's chief
of staff okay
so if you're wondering how far up the
chain they're willing to go they're
getting there baby they're getting there
and the sharks are in the [ __ ] water
now
mark short
we've we've watched some of the
deposition to the january 6 select
earrings right
and that's the one reason why he came on
cnn here but
she just she had to ask him about this
mad gads clip so watch
our america
is proudly ultra magga not some low
energy roadside rhino safari
[Applause]
on that note let me just say what
everybody here knows
mike pence will never be president
nice guy
not a leader
so the aim here is the
is because mark short was the chief of
staff of vice president mike pence and
mark short has been a staff member for
mike pence for many years
he's been alongside mike pence for a
long time so mark short is no
gym as it were
this guy is this guy is a complete
enabler of someone like mike pence but
listen to what he says and how he wants
i mean he just wads gets up and dumps
him in the [ __ ] treasure listen
mark
well i don't know if mike pencil runs
for president 2024 but
i don't think matt gates will have an
impact on that in fact i'd be surprised
if he was still voting it's more likely
he'll be in prison for child sex
trafficking by 2024 and i'm actually
surprised that florida law enforcement
still allows them to speak to teenage
conferences like that so i'm not too
worried about matt gates things
oh i can't i can't it's it's it's golden
it's [ __ ] golden just one sunday the
other yeah the other thing too is like
on sunday i tweeted out something kind
of similar which was like he said this i
was like matt gates said a very
misogynistic
uh
gave a very
misogynistic speech at the student
action summit what's more concerning is
the fact that he did it in front of a
room full of teenagers right and was
allowed to like that's that's what is it
is crazy is a guy who you know alleged
sex trafficking despite the fact that
you know joel greenberg has evidence and
has indicated that yeah matt gates was
right next to me when we were [ __ ]
venmo in each other and you know sex
trafficking um
but the fact that it's like of all
people
of all [ __ ] people that you're gonna
bring to a student action summit with
teenagers and you're gonna speak to like
i get it that republicans get off on
that [ __ ] and this is the new way this
is the new world order for them
that's what they want
but the fact that he's actually allowed
to be in a room in a [ __ ] room
full of teenagers
to give that speech wow it's [ __ ]
like a piece of [ __ ]
well i want to get to some other news
here so let's go through the uh tweety
tweets and trendy trends um
maybe should we start the [ __ ] list
we're way way beyond we are yeah 23
minutes shitless
we won't we won't do the music we won't
we'll just do the [ __ ] this round up
here um i want to show you a very taco
tuesday very important talking about
babies
listen
taco tuesday is very important here on
the tony michaels podcast because me and
gabe have had several debates of what a
taco is what a taco is and everyone
knows that gabe is a taco connoisseur
and a burrito connoisseur
tonight
i'm telling you man i'm having my secret
family recipe with tacos well actually
gabe secret family recipe i'm not going
to give it away of
what
how the seasoning works but it's a
72-hour marinade right
steak yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] okay so here's what
i'll tell you there's some more taco
tuesday news gabe and i need to ask you
a question i know i know what this is
about important question to ask you
there is a certain type of taco that has
been discontinued in our country i know
and i am very disappointed i know a lot
of other people are really [ __ ] upset
but i want to know is a choco taco is it
a taco
it's an ice cream taco
so it is a taco it's a taco it is a taco
it's just an ice cream top it's klondike
not not blue bunny it's klondike yeah
yeah choco tacos discontinuing after i
read that yesterday i was very upset to
hear about that i was like oh and he was
saying i don't even get choco tacos that
often like if i see him in the
supermarket i'm like yeah i'll grab
something or like a or a drumstick or
something
but
they're they're still tacos it's a
dessert taco technically i mean like you
can have you can make i mean you can
make a like if you really wanted you
could make a pancake taco right you can
make a crepe taco right these are all
like in some ways every country has a
different form of taco right you've got
something that is a wrap bread form and
then you've got contents inside and yes
i consider a choco taco to be a taco
right it's a lot of
you know there's a lot going on with it
but it's a taco
i mean it's got a waffle cone as the
shell right
which you're not into hard shells but
apparently on a taco taco well here's
the i feel well you have to you can't
have a soft shell why not
you can do anything you want gabe this
is a mercury
okay i i just feel like the
the consistency but also you have to
maintain like the hard shell keeps
the the ice cream in place if you have a
soft shell
you might break through i mean we can go
over the logistics of how well see
here's the thing here's the thing the
audience doesn't know it's like we've
had these debates on air about taco we
have had these debates even longer off
the air
of what a taco is what a taco what's a
burrito what constitutes these things
and i've learned so much about tacos
that this useless information but is it
useless it's the most important this is
the most important on a tuesday every
day on a tuesday at subaru or tuesday
sure yeah if you were like hey what is
the secret to life and i would say tacos
tacos are that secrets
so many things you can make
with just tortillas you know you're
making your soda very jealous right now
you're making your
here's the sodastream in my bunker here
i don't even have a sodastream oh my god
what are you no wonder no wonder you
haven't been able to keep it together
here it's just you're all over the place
i know no choco tacos
no choco tacos nose no bubbly water it's
just it's ridiculous
well so the other the other possibly
positive news about this situation is
that while they are the choco taco that
of the choco taco okay uh alexis ohanian
who is the who is the original he's the
founder and ceo
former ceo of reddit
tweeted out and he was like hey look
who's by the way very very rich right
he's um
uh he he is he mega millions rich
because you heard the mega millions is
up to 800 million dollars
i should probably buy a ticket then i i
said i if i won i would bring back the
choco taco is that where you're going
with this
well that's so what he did what he did
is he said online let me see if i can
find the tweet he said um
he would be
willing
to buy it from them
and i don't know if he gave a price or
anything like that but he said his tweet
was uh what's their reasoning for
discontinuing this thing
is there a good reason that that i i
i didn't read if there was a reason from
them so i don't know if it's because of
um
the aspect of people not buying anymore
or like if there's other things but he
said he said because unilever owns them
unilever right they own clients a bigger
company and unilever they make they make
uh shampoo yeah
if you look at a map it's one of those
companies that own like you're like oh
what are the six companies that own
everything they're like the disney of
food and hair products exactly yeah yeah
they're uh the case studies they have
are pretty interesting how they um which
speaking of disney did you hear about
this hulu fiasco i did i did people
people are [ __ ] pissed at hulu do you
have hulu i have hulu i do i have hulu
too and i actually watch a show um
called the old man on there oh my god
yeah i started watching that because of
you
it is just watch the first episode
i just want to say uh i just want to say
that the fact that he can
he can do that at that age like the
fight scenes and stuff just on the first
episode i was like hell yeah it is jeff
bridges man he can kick ass and take
names he's the dude man he's the dude
one of my favorite one of my one of my
favorite films is that he's ever been in
though is true grit that's gotta he does
such a good job in tr in the remake of
true grit i think it was 2011 2012. but
anyways
the old man but it is such a great
series but hulu is under a lot of fire
um we see
fred gutenberg here it says please make
sure to watch and share this ad and then
cancel hulu today do not let them censor
your rights and freedoms and safety now
the senate democrats tried to put this
ad on hulu i think they were successful
for some time but hulu actually took the
ads down um they're banning
they're banning um
gun safety ads they're banning um pro
pro choice ads and i i i believe there's
one more
set of ads that they're banning
um and i'm not sure
i haven't seen anything i don't know
what i'm curious so like i'm part of a
family plan through someone else or
whatever you know and
they pay to not have ads so i don't even
see the ads
oh so so you're safe i don't even i
didn't even know this was well like yeah
whatever i mean like i'm already guess
you know the removal of ads but i didn't
even know this was a thing until i read
about it today
but the other thing is like i'm curious
to know how many people who use hulu
don't pay for ads
well i mean that that's possibility
senate democrats tweeted here you know
about the hulu rejecting the ads to call
out gop attacks on abortion access and
gun safety um
their shady policies
amount to outrageous political
censorship so i haven't seen the actual
statement from hulu like why they took
these ads down but it does it does seem
to smell
um very similar to when like fox news
censors certain political ads because
they don't like what they say you know
because because
a television station or a streaming
platform absolutely has the right to
take a political ad down that is lies
they do not have to hear that they do
not yeah um which is almost 99.9 of
republican ads but you know i digress on
that but as we know
this
hulu is owned
by disney just like we were talking
unilever is the disney of hair care and
food products disney is the
is is the
mega machine of content and disney owns
hulu
um i don't know when they bought hulu
it's been in recent years that they well
they
they have a stake in hulu right exactly
what it is they don't own it outright
but they own a majority stake and that
was years ago i think they they can
control hulu let's let's be frank now
they are a separate organization but
here's what i'll tell you is this this
[ __ ] woke disney's woke [ __ ] well we
even have i i listened to while i was
out um
doing our thing over the weekend when i
was trying to ignore social media i was
listening in the hotel room
uh at a local ad for a local politician
and the words in the ad were disney's
woke biden's broke i'm like oh my god
you people are [ __ ] pathetic they
can't come up with a better argument
than that
they sound like uh like
like uh future future musicians or
rappers they're just like already come
with the rhymes they're like woke broke
oh my god oh yeah it's it's fantastic
that they can rhyme it's really it's
really inventive but
this whole disney's woke thing shouldn't
this put this to bed that's what i was
like i'm not gonna you would think that
if you're like hey cancel mine yeah yeah
that's i mean like if you if you were to
look at this and say
uh disney is woke okay well disney is
you know they're majority owners they're
like a stake of of hulu
you would think that somebody who was
woke would want to keep the message of
the left on the platform right
right i get that but if you remove it
then you would say they're not woke
right and then you would also i mean
like you know then there's a whole
argument of like oh is it free speech or
whatever and then you have a
conservative republicans like oh look
you know yeah you shouldn't be talking
about those things because it's pro this
agenda and it's like so you so you are
you are in favor of then suppressing
the thing right so you're you're you're
cancelled culture what you right well
here's the ad because that's the other
thing i thought is okay well maybe it's
the ad that caused hulu to do this but
this is the ad and i don't think it's
the actual ad that caused them to pull
it down because watch the ad the supreme
court's decision to overturn roe v wade
is the result of a coordinated
republican attack on abortion it will
rip away a woman's right to make her own
health care decisions make no mistake
republicans will not stop at overturning
roe they will make abortion illegal
nationwide even in causes of rape incest
or to save the mother's life
your rights are on the ballot in
november make your voice heard dscc d
triple c and democratic action are
responsible for the content of this
advertising frankly i'm really
disappointed that the
that the democrats here the d triple c
and the dscc and the democratic action
um they didn't go far enough they're not
provocative enough i think i think this
is a really wimpy ad to be honest with
you well i wonder if and i haven't seen
the other ads but i would unless there's
some issues i think this is the one that
triggered it this is the one that
triggered them to be taken down i don't
need that that's that's what they claim
so it's hard to think the only thing
from this ad that i could be like oh
okay
is like
the hypothetical nature right even
though it isn't really hypothetical them
saying they want to ban well they're on
the floor of the house they're talking
about right i know i know i know so like
i don't know if it's that aspect where
it's like it hasn't happened yet like if
it's like this hasn't like i'm not i'm
trying to make sense of why and i don't
know that's what i was trying to do this
morning
i was trying to do this morning like why
is is there a reason why hulu and i
thought well maybe it's the ad you know
maybe maybe it's because they don't want
to air republican ads alongside of it
because that could be another case is
right applying i mean like are we are we
not hearing about the republican ads
well i mean that and that's the other
thing too is some some platforms may
have a policy where if they air one
political ad they will they will air the
other political ad in that same content
that may be their policy and they
definitely don't want to air the [ __ ]
lies in the garbage and the fascism
right right so they're not airing that
in in in perpetuity for fairness or
whatever however how are their policies
they're trying to remain neutral
possibly well i mean they're taking
another way i don't know what hulu's
reasoning is at this point but i'll tell
you something hulu is going to have to
make a statement very soon
and they're going to have to address
this issue very soon why they did it
specifically
and they better not lie about it i i
would say that it will make it worse on
them if they do lie about it because
i'll tell you i'm gonna keep my hulu
subscription until i find out why but if
i find out they're [ __ ] trying to
cover [ __ ] up and hide something that's
when i'll cancel when you're not being
outright honest because they may have
made this decision in an honest
based on their policies and they felt
like it was the best decision for their
policies and we'll see but if they start
lying
[ __ ] that's not you're lying to
cover up you know these [ __ ] fascists
[ __ ] not gonna be okay with me so
let's go back i want to go to our title
today um gabe because
the story is is that john roberts was
trying to petition
um specifically it seems like brett
kavanaugh uh because he thought he could
turn brick kavanaugh on this road
decision to not to not let dobbs
overturn roe v wade yeah um even since
december here's the thing i actually
think this story is a bunch of [ __ ] i
think all this is is to do damage repair
on john roberts that way john roberts
can still go to a steakhouse and eat a
steak unlike brett kavanaugh i really do
think that this is a bunch of [ __ ]
um the way that this is framed up
because if chief justice john roberts
was so [ __ ] hell-bent on making sure
that dobbs decision didn't overturn roe
v wade why the [ __ ] didn't he vote in
the way of that yeah
come on give me a [ __ ] break he this
is all [ __ ] i don't believe this for
a second now this is apparently a
reporter who has a good reputation and
stuff but i think she's being fed a
bunch of [ __ ] about john roberts
about brett kavanaugh i don't know i
want to i want to see more about this
story but it seems very suspicious to me
that all of a sudden john roberts wants
to be the [ __ ] hero here of roe when
it got overturned and he voted to
[ __ ] overturn it
give me a [ __ ] break
give me a [ __ ] break and and the
other thing too about this story
that they're that they're saying is
they're blaming
they're blaming
the uh
the leak
of why he couldn't turn
kavanagh uh here rolling stone has it
yeah which is which i think is the most
ridiculous thing to say is like oh the
leak ruined it for me to over to get
some like no other [ __ ] didn't
right
leak if anything the leak would make it
possibly the thing that would change
somebody's mind right because now
they're under under pressure
but if the leak didn't happen no one
would know
what their opinion was until the very
end but you know i got to thinking this
morning about this and i was like
because i was on the same path you were
but i'm like what if
what if what if these [ __ ] needed cover
what if they wanted cover and this is
their cover after the fact
right so what if they needed cover
what if what if they used brett
kavanaugh this [ __ ] excuse that
somehow he was open-minded to row which
he's not right he never was it was a
[ __ ] lie yeah and and they started to
to provide cover this whole time to
overturn roe
so that john roberts had this excuse
after the fact so that they could blame
what probably seems to be if if this is
really an attempt
to leak to change the decision to
overturn roe then you would only have to
assume that it was a right winger who
[ __ ] leaked this thing yeah which is
what we said on the show right when it
happened right yeah i said
we said when it happened it's probably a
[ __ ] right winger who bleak this i
joked about i was i was joking about
jenny thomas and saying that maybe it
was a way to distract from jan six talks
you know and so you know her husband
uh you know clarence is like i'll do
this for you you know because god forbid
this woman
you know there's no way that this couple
you know clarence thomas and jenny
thomas
you know were not
in talking matt like
kind of level of what's going on with
january 6th in the election right this
[ __ ] crazy q a person so the idea
that somebody whether it be a clerk or
clarence or you know jenny secret you
know sneaking in after after hours
somebody leaked it but it was on the
right like what it doesn't really
benefit the left because everyone's
gonna fight it on the left
the only way that you would do it on the
right if you're trying to distract from
a bigger story at play well and i mean
this is all christian nationalism type
[ __ ] this whole overturning roe v wade
and which is very appropriate because
christian nationalist is trending
because of this [ __ ] nazi oh god
marjorie taylor green now i'm not sure
if there's another specific video where
she's talking about [ __ ] how she's
proud to be a christian nationalist or
whatever yeah um but she's a [ __ ]
nazi that's what it is and of course
we've watched several videos of her
bragging about it
um on on air not just on her tv show but
others bring about how she's a she's
she's so excited let me let me go to the
marge thread
and see if we can find some of this
video that's going to be an interesting
thread well here is um here's apparently
one is getting christian nationalism
and maddow because she's got mad out
trending too hopefully this helps some
of you that are brainwashed by liars
like rachel maddow what the [ __ ] does
that mean number one i don't watch
rachel maddow and i criticized rachel
mano last week yeah yeah exactly extent
i told rachel manohar she was wrong
right and and every anyone else who used
that everyone started freaking out that
night including don winslow was freaking
out you know caused everyone else to
have this freak out and we were chatting
and i was like that's not how i
interpreted this yeah i didn't know i
didn't when i read the actual [ __ ]
thing it actually it projected the
actual opposite to me and then merrick
garland goes out in front of a camera
the next day and says you goddamn right
we'll [ __ ] prosecute his ass anyone
no one's above the law right now she
says here mar merge says here
merge
her foot green
says who by the way has never met me in
her entire life why the [ __ ] would
rachel maddow have to meet you to
[ __ ] comment you're a congressperson
you [ __ ] idiot how how
what in the [ __ ] is wrong with these
people i don't know how meeting someone
would change the way in which you look
at someone right if i know what your
voting record is and how you speak to
thousands of people
and how you tweet out to millions of
people we need to meet you i don't need
to meet you at all i know exactly what
you stand for frankly to be frank with
you i wouldn't want to meet this if i
know that you harass
the victims
right of gun violence
of school shootings i know exactly who
you are i don't need to see anything
else i just need to see you harass a kid
harass you know exactly that you're a
piece of [ __ ] harass seven members of
her colleagues and then have a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] who sexually harasses her
colleagues on the capitol steps on her
show and they're laughing and giggling
about it like it's [ __ ] oh it's so
it's comedy no it's sexual harassment
nobody wants to meet you outside of
those okay the only time that people
want to meet her was that line of people
that were at the student action summit
who again indoctrinated into believing
that this is the way forward you know
white is right blonde hair blue eye
aryan nation nazis outside republicans
don't you know condemn it that's who
want to meet those are the people that
want to meet marjorie taylor green those
are the only people the people that look
like her are the people that want to
meet her
well she goes on to say here and this is
the pack to the soro [ __ ] right
and gets paid to lie about me by her
hard left employers at msnbc who else
would she be paid by besides her
employers what the [ __ ] are you talking
about how [ __ ] brain dead does this
[ __ ] idiot have to be to realize that
an employer pays their employee and she
says what a pitiful way to earn a
paycheck well that you don't earn your
paycheck
right
you don't have your paycheck
she she doesn't earn her paycheck she
does she's in no committees she's
[ __ ] she's
she's hamstrung to go in front of the
house floor and only talk on that
microphone only introduce amendments on
the house right or she can't do it
through committee well she's paid to be
on her on her podcast right she paid as
a representative to sit and go have
interviews with people like
alex stein and others spreading you know
disinformation right what a pitiful
ready to earn a paycheck dude oh my god
remember marger taylor green is the
woman who was literally obsessed with
aoc aoc had to upper security because of
what she did before marjorie taylor
green was even a representative
she was at aoc's office harassing her
through a mailbox there was that video
that came out there you know she is
someone who should not be in office she
is a she is a stain on the american
democracy and what it stands for and
uses the constitution and christianity
her her fake christianity as an excuse
for why she's a good person right but a
good person again wouldn't harass a kid
who's a victim of a student a school
shooting right like good people don't do
that christians don't do that this party
is not christian this is this is a fake
a fake party that that that is that is
uh propped up on
on on fake ideals and and morals
speaking of fake would you actually
trust any nazi who gropes uh uh fake
donald trump's crouch let's watch yeah
he does he's fantastic this guy right
here he's great
stated up in there in the mucky swamp
diane always has to grab him by the
crotch
what the [ __ ] would you trust any nazi
no i wouldn't dress every time i see
that [ __ ] video i'm always like what
the [ __ ] was she thinking where she was
like yeah monkey swamp now let me let me
touch this flat cardboard cold dick
of donald trump
because ooh what gets me so wet is
touching this [ __ ] cold flat
cardboard donald trump
dick oh my god well we have to end it on
that note thanks a lot gabe i appreciate
you i don't know the slam dunk i'm sure
we can we could find another thing to
end well you know we're we're at two
hours we're
we're we're going over time i've got a
lot of meetings this afternoon
um
to to get to i've got a lot of stuff i
got to do that no i get it it's fine
yeah yeah no yeah let's go let's leave
bye but every but every but everyone
else everyone else tomorrow because we
do this show every single weekday monday
through friday noon eastern eleventh
century on youtube twitter twitch noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific
we also signed mccas from the mind as
touch facebook page don't forget to go
follow texas paul thank you to texas
paul for coming and talking us today
always the play bottom of the first hour
um and and until tomorrow game until
tomorrow surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born had asked